many teams lots of players they get into
batting slumps buddy you're gonna take
one of these very qualified select
batteries to sub in we have piace in in
lemonade we have the bear jew from
inglorious bastards we have Harley Quinn
in Suicide Squad and a obviously fan
favorite Al Capone Indian Tasha balls
baseball I mean I'd like to go to the
Jew bear because I'm part Jewish airg oh
that's tough one I haven't seen this
movie but he looks pretty bad as an r8
great movie I would recommend it batter
up you're on deck he just looks like
he's ready to go up to the plate and get
something get something done for the
team I know that you're your specialty
isn't on the baseball field which of
these celeb hitters very qualified
people who's your number one pick Josh
Al Capone
great movie Al Capone is a good alcohol
fan favorites and if you're if you're
gonna give some some female power which
is it gonna be I don't think there's a
person in the world who doesn't like
beyoncé's little girly lock up 10 part
i'm taking beyonce i'll be taking back
yeah no dough just the way she holds the
batch you got a good swing i think i
should get far with that so it's got
some swagger got from the guys such nice
guy she gots good i'm oak behind on that
back i'm gonna have to go beyond sit
with how popular she is i think she'd be
able to draw a walk just because
pictures would be intimidated to face
her rather be crazy
you slow down you don't love you like a
love